خمس نقاط مئويه كانت هي الفارقه بين
الرئيس التركي الحالي اردوغان متقدما بها
على منافسه مرشح تحالف المعارضه كما
الكليج دارولو نصف نقطه فقط كان كافيا
ليبقي مفاتيح القصر الجمهوري في يده لكنه
وجد نفسه مضطرا لخوض جوله اعاده عسى ان
يحسم الامر لصالحه بدا
[موسيقى]
فرنسا
انتهج الرئيس استراتيجيه لا تختلف كثيرا
عن تلك التي اتبعها في الجوله الاولى من
السباق الرئاسي بدا من تركيزه على انه
القادر على اعاده اعمار المناطق التي
دمرتها الزلازل الاخيره الى تجديده الوعود
بنقل تركيا الى مصاف الدول المتقدمه
بالتزامن مع انطلاقه المئويه الثانيه
لجمهوريتها في
وضع اردوغان اوراقه الرابحه على الطاوله
منذ الجوله الاولى من الصناعات الدفاعيه
الى اتهامات المعارضه بمحاباه الارهاب الى
ادائه في مناطق الزلزال هو مرتاح وليس
هناك ضروره ليخرج من قبعه الساحر ارنبا
في المقابل بدات لهجته كمال كريجدار اوغلو
اكثر تصعيدا حيث انتهج خطابا متشددا تجاه
اللاجئين في محاوله لكسب اصوات القوميين
والشباب والتركيز على التحدي الاكبر وهو
اخراج مناصري المعارضه من حاله احباط
محتمله تسببت فيها نتائج الجوله الاولى
يكتشرون
مقاربتك لجدار اوغلو في الجوله الثانيه
اعتمدت التخويف مما سيحدث في حال لم ينجح
وهي معاكسه لنظيرتها في الجوله الاولى
التي كانت تركز على رسائل ايجابيه من
الصعب الجزم باداء هذه المقاربه فالبلاد
تذهب لجوله اعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لاول مره في تاريخها
تتضارب استطلاعات الراي حول من سيكون
الرئيس الثالث عشر للبلاد هذا ما حصل قبيل
الجوله الاولى وهذا قد يحصل في الجوله
الثانيه ويعزوا خبراء الراي العام تضارب
الاستطلاعات لكون بعض مراكزها قريبا من
هذا الحزب او ذاك
هي اشبه ما تكون بمعركه كسر عظم بين خصمين
يقول اردوغان ان عنوانها هو الصراع على
بقاء تركيا فيرد بانها ترقى لان تكون
استفتاء على مصير الوطن هي معركه الفائز
فيها من يقنع ناخبين اكثر بان الغدا معه
افضل
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره